good to have you with us welcome to the
newshour ethiopia state media is
reporting that the second phase
of filling the controversial grand
renaissance dam is nearly complete
now the issue has raised tensions with
its neighbors
egypt and sudan want a binding deal over
the filling
and the dam's operations and have
approached the un security council to
intervene
ethiopia says the project is essential
to its development but cairo and
khartoum fear
it could restrict their access to water
let's go straight over to catherine soy
joins me now from addis ababa it does
seem catherine
that matters are coming to a head in the
region
yes it does we're still trying to get in
touch with officials
and the ministry of of irrigation to
give us more detail of this
but then it has been announced at the
state broadcaster and other government
news agencies saying that the dumb
feeling is near completion
uh quoting sources at the ministry of
information
who are saying that there were no major
problems but as you mentioned it has
caused a lot of tension
uh between ethiopia and those downstream
countries egypt and sudan
were worried about what this could do to
their own water flows along the nile
they
are saying that there needs to be a
binding
uh legal agreement before any operations
on the dam had asked
ethiopia to stop this process until that
agreement is reached but ethiopia has
said no that cannot happen we will
continue
the prime minister has been speaking
about it saying
that ethiopia does not intend to harm
any of these countries but then it's
going to do whatever it can his
administration is going to do whatever
it can
to protect this uh process of the
feeling that started earlier
in the month you talked about the u.n
security council meeting
um the members of the u.n security
council meeting all seem to be leaning
towards going back to talks mediated by
the african union
we know previous talks mediated by the
african union have failed
but ethiopia also says that this is an
africa problem that needs to be dealt
with
by the african union egypt and sudan are
saying
that we they need mediation from the u.n
the european union
and so on but a lot of people here in
ethiopia
are saying that they're waiting for this
project to be complete they're waiting
uh they're hoping for those benefits of
65
million ethiopians that's half the
population
are not do not have access to
electricity we've been speaking to some
of them who are saying that they're very
proud of
this project it's a project that they uh
raised money
to fund so um a lot of uncertainty
in the region but ethiopians here saying
that they want the project
to come to an end they want to benefit
from that uh
dumb uh catherine uh over the past few
years we've been following the you know
construction of this dam the mediation
as you mentioned
through the un security council and uh
through the african union as matters
have come to a head
it seems that diplomacy can only go so
far
so one does have to wonder is there a
concern about any conflict because
africa
doesn't really need another conflict
well there is a huge concern about what
this may do
um egypt has and sudan both are saying
that they do not want any conflict but
recently we saw
um training of forces uh by both
countries
um and this course concerned here in uh
ethiopia
in ethiopia as well we've seen a build
up of uh you know
troops around uh the you know the dumb
filling site
um we had the prime minister saying that
one of the reasons
why they withdrew soldiers from tigray
where there's that ongoing conflict so
one of the reasons that we drew
uh soldiers from there is to uh prepare
for um a possible external threat so all
this
talk is causing quite a lot of concern
but all the countries are agreeing
that there is no appetite for a conflict
they say that
diplomacy is the only way to go the u.n
security council has said that
um these countries should go back to
talks
mediated by the african union there's a
lot of concern yes
but i mean a lot of people we've talked
to here in ethiopia
and in those other two countries as well
saying that there is no appetite for a
conflict this needs to be
resolved but a binding solution a
binding legal agreement
must be in place um so that everyone can
be
on the same page on the operations of
this dam catherine soy there for us in
addis ababa thank you